bienvenido a france 24
puntualmente cuáles son los daños a la
biodiversidad que causará esta megaobra
sabemos que menos del 1 por ciento del
total del costo estimado estará
destinado a la mitigación del impacto
ambiental
y mucho menos que eso valentina y
desafortunadamente tenemos claro que ya
los avances están causando grandes
estragos grandes daños a todo el paisaje
parte de los problemas que se están
suscitando es uno la deforestación que
estamos viendo ahorita en la pantalla 2
el impacto al acuífero que en la
península de yucatán es subterráneo y
que toda la roca de la península yucatán
es básicamente roca caliza muy frágil
cualquier camión o tren muy muy pesado
la va a romper y tres los servicios
ecosistémicos que presta la
biodiversidad incluidos los murciélagos
están en riesgo y eso implicaría un daño
a la salud y a la vida humana a la vida
animal y a la vida vegetal
existe alguna forma de construcción que
pueda ser menos dañina para el
territorio y para los ecosistemas estoy
absolutamente seguro de que si
pudiéramos sentarnos con los expertos
técnicos que tiene el presidente lópez
obrador
viendo estos temas pero que abran la
puerta a los expertos de muchas
universidades y otras instituciones
académicas de mexico encontraríamos una
manera mucho más factible de asegurar la
sustentabilidad en esta obra no estamos
en contra del tren estamos en contra de
las condiciones en las que se está
realizando el tren y hemos invitado al
presidente a dialogar con nosotros qué
es lo que él ofreció al inicio de su
mandato y no lo ha hecho
bueno el presidente lópez obrador
asegura que cuenta con el apoyo de los
pueblos indígenas para realizar estas
obras realmente existe ese respaldo
el presidente realizó algunas consultas
en algunos de los lugares principalmente
en ciudades en el norte de la península
y esa gente se se expresó respecto al
tren de manera positiva pero ojo en ese
momento no había ninguna idea de por
dónde iba a pasar el tren de los daños
que iba a hacer de qué tipo de tren iba
a ser etcétera hoy con tantos cambios
que ha habido porque lo han cambiado
muchas veces tú sabes que el tramo 5 ha
sido cambiado de estar junto a las a los
hoteles hasta el metido en la selva esto
no lo aprobaron las comunidades de
ninguna manera y las comunidades que
están metidas en la selva que es a las
que está afectando el tramo 5 son
precisamente a las que nunca se les
consultó no tienen ninguna posibilidad
de decir no yo no quiero el tren o si
quiero el tren porque no los han ido a
ver